I am so grateful that you're here and
I'm very excited about today's guests
first I'm gonna let you know that I will
be coming to Oroville casino
this coming Saturday February 15th had
sold out Toronto Ontario
February 20th through the 22nd there are
still tickets available for the 20th
February 27th in Red Bank New Jersey the
28th in Oxon Hill Maryland February 29th
at the Newport News Ferguson Center for
the Arts in Virginia and now March 7th
in Maui Hawaii at the castle theater
those tickets will go on sale on Tuesday
of this week I'm so excited about
today's guests
one is the 2017 and 2019 professional
bull riding world champion he's on the
circuit right now defending his title
he's 22 years old mister Jess Lockwood
and also joining us is the host of the
Matt West now podcast he is the voice of
professional bull riding
PBR announcer Matt West and you can see
professional bull riding this coming
weekend at AT&T Stadium in Dallas for
the global Cup and you can also find it
on CBS and CBS Sports Network very happy
to be here today with mr. Jess Lockwood
and mr. Matt West I love physical t-bone
shrimp broth medium what I like is a big
shrimp in the Gulf of Mexico though yeah
you'll see woman like a coffee company
the smoking cigarette the morning yeah
got a rockstar ball cap with a mullet in
the back this was like a seniority vest
don't like even worked working at
Hooters yeah yeah I need a Pensacola
Beach man I ain't been there in a minute
dude Hooters used to be the place used
to be used to be how do you just 22 oh
yeah yes custom rods like your blood
back in college college Hooters was was
a [ __ ] it was a place on the road to
slick the sides in my head back with a
jelly package we didn't have any hair
gel yep I get off just like a light
strawberry or something go down each
side and I go to Hooters when I would
get an appetizer yeah and just stare
straight into the eyes of every woman
till they asked me to leave that's a
good play dude I never could make eye
contact oh yeah yeah I was real shy oh
really nervous so I just sit there till
like I fell off the stool and then
security would ask me oh that same kinda
yeah see if wants to get their attention
yeah that's why I did it yeah you know
they're like oh we got to check on him
yeah it's like the kid that uh
pretended to be drowning so the
lifeguard would come down and give you
mouth-to-mouth oh yeah yeah yeah that
move
yeah Sandlin what'd it say in LA yes
thanks oh yeah the good movie man it's a
good movie so let me so let's get you
guys as jobs clear so your Rother yep
I'm a rider not one of the best riders
yet in the 2017 and 2019 I want it run
world title and who won 2018 ke keep a
check oh oh God
it wasn't my hair it wasn't no I got my
ass kicked really yeah and do you credit
anything to like like what cost you it
or do you think it was just a bad bull
what was it cause um she we they talk
about all the time world champion
hangover kind of just yeah I didn't go
into the season as pinpointed as I
should've and then second or even the
offseason we ride another animal riding
on other animals but I did go partying
yeah you gotta do yeah I was celebrated
yeah I wasn't twenty year old kid went
and hung out at my buddy's college for a
bit and hung out and had fun and then
pre-marriage yeah this was pre marriage
okay so yeah I can talk about this yeah
yeah Christian funny talking waterslide
he's talking yeah yeah yeah yeah movies
just you know it's sad but that's
actually kind of true yeah he's not much
of a partier now I'm not too hard
so 2019 it was a did was that like a
comeback time for you do you feel like
yeah after that 2018 season I was pretty
pissed off and I had a chip on my
shoulder going in the new season had to
prove something so it was it was a good
season just awkward thanks for being
here today your job with it's totally
different right I just talked for a
living yeah it's not hard so how does it
go when I'm get to the arena when you
get to the actual event so I mean it's
just like anything else like like when
you start putting your stand up together
like we'll start putting notes together
about these guys I'll talk about you
know if he broke his collarbone or
whatever storylines statistics we've got
to know know the Bulls got to know all
the guys and be able to kind of tell
that story to somebody that's never seen
it before
yeah and find a way to make it
interesting to them like that's I I put
pressure on myself to bring in brand new
fans that have no idea what the hell's
going on and make them leave going holy
[ __ ] I'm invested in this guy or this
bowl or I just love the sport it's one
of the fat
that's growing sports in America yeah
yeah why is that you think man I think
it's like I think the intensity of it
like and the respect for what these guys
do because it's literally the only sport
in the world that a guy can lose his
life practicing I mean because they
practice on real-life Bulls and when
you're putting that much on the line
every single time like it's not like you
show up in half-ass a game like these
guys got to show up and and give it a
thousand percent every time so how could
you not be invested in something like
that yeah yeah you can't get up in you
can't spray paint a sheep in a lot of
the audience and get out there take it
easy if you don't stay on you don't get
paid that's another thing a lot of guys
have contract salaries you buck off and
you go on a streak where you fall off a
lot you're probably either getting
kicked off the tour and not paid or
you're losing sponsors all sorts of
stuff so yeah nobody's sitting in a
control room punching a button telling
them that hey this Bulls going to turn
left
giving them a little the old Astros turn
to the left or anything like that yeah
you don't get to Omaha Omaha when you're
up no right yeah there's no timeout hey
stop this ain't comfortable it's it's
when you're going you're you're in for
it so the size of these bulls what is it
like what are we talking I'd say an
average 116 1,700 but [ __ ] there'll be
ones up to 2,200 pounds there are some
big bastards out there and you don't get
to meet them before you don't get to
like say anything to them hey buddy I
mean you can but most of the time they
don't care about your opinion they want
to get in there buck you off go back to
their feeding their cows and why do they
hate having something on their back they
just don't like it it's just that it's
bred into him at this point you know
back in the day it was kind of hit and
miss bull dude buck hard bulls wouldn't
but nowadays they're bred to do this and
they know their job so it's to get you
off as soon as they can and go back to
the back pens and as if you're like so
the different rounds you guys get into a
bull riding event right so you start
there's how many competitors are gonna
be in an event how does it how does the
event go throughout the evening or
sounds like it starts with 35 every
weekend the best 35 guys in the world
show up and typically on like a two-day
weekend
all 35 will get on two bulls they'll get
on a boat like Friday night and then
another bull on Saturday night and then
the top 15 guys after those two rounds
will get on a third bull
they're like the best bulls in the world
so you know you it's like you're playing
in the major leagues and then you got to
step it up a notch in that final 15 and
those are the guys that really get paid
that's how you win so that's when you
get that money round a Sunday oh yeah
that's championship round you go and
lead in that sucker pick a good bull do
your job most likely gonna win it and
did you ever bull ride man I tried it
one time
why'd it was the dumbest thing I've ever
done and I enrolled in the same College
three times that's no bull [ __ ] I've
done some stupid stuff but I tried it
man because like I was so invested in
what the guys were doing and I was I was
friends with all them I had so much
respect for him I was like I can't get
up there and talk about it and not know
what it feels like I still don't know
what it feels like cuz it knocked me
smooth the hell out I have no idea what
happened but really yeah it was dumb it
was so dumb and I got on a bull that
like legit couldn't have jumped over
that Cup it was so bad man I was the
worst bull attempter ever why it sucked
and so you get into the event you get on
top of the bull you're in the it's a pen
what do they call it button shoes
[ __ ] shoot in the chute mm-hmm okay
now once you sit on it do they let like
how long do you get to be on it before
that gate opens so you're you just kind
of go through the motions your routine
but once the judge think I have a judge
sitting up on top of there and once he
feels like you're taking too long he'll
put you on a clock and you got 30
seconds and regardless if that Bulls
going crazy in there you got 30 seconds
so it's best to get in there and go as
fast you possibly can
which we want to because it's sometimes
more dangerous in that steel metal chute
than it is out in the arena so can you
do you make that call when you're in
there do you say hey I'm ready now just
do you have a coach that's right guys it
says hey look this is the time is right
now let's open the gate now how does
that work know if you kind of like I
said go through your routine and then
once you're ready you slide up on them
and you nod your head or you can just
tell them like okay open the gate
but most of us nod our head like that no
you feel you ready Indian zucchini
because the only thing I could equate it
to is being you know and non rider I
mean I have a Jeep Grand Cherokee
but that's about as wild as I did so the
only thing I could equate it to is being
on like I would think being on like a
thing at an amusement park or something
does it have that kind of feel like when
you're getting to the time you you know
you're about to you know Joe drops out
from under oh yeah it's one that
rollercoasters climbing and you can feel
your body kind of start to get that
adrenaline going it's like oh [ __ ] it's
coming it's coming that's what it's like
when you're in the chute doing your
routine and then when you get up a nod
it's kind of after when you nod it's
like when that roller coaster drop it
just goes black you know what you're
doing but it's all reaction you don't
have time to think you don't have time
to do anything it's just hold on for
dear life is there a place where your
head goes I can imagine if you start to
get to mental about it then you're you
probably gonna it's gonna be a loss like
I can imagine if to stay in like a flow
almost oh yeah if you're if you're in
the chute and you're thinking all right
I know this bull he's gonna turn out of
here and go left if you start thinking
that when you're in the chute you
screwed yourself because that bowl has a
mind of its own
you make a move right out of there to go
left he's gonna go straight or he's
gonna go the opposite way just to dump
you damn is there a feeling you get some
time when you're on it like man this
thing is not it's not a good day for
this mister that time of the month for
this when it's there's there anything
you get this one's had a tough week or
something you get any that is there any
vibe coming up for the bull or not
really not really when he when he rolls
into that chute usually you can tell
kind of you can get a little vibe off of
him not by feel just by looking at him
if he's kind of droopy eared or if he
looks real skinny than normal you can
kind of tell well he doesn't look like
he's gonna have his day but then they
can surprise you and they can rock your
house off quick yeah that's what's funny
about it because you see guys that like
like me I always try to match him up and
I'm like okay he's definitely gonna ride
that one he's definitely gonna ride that
one that one's gonna be tough for him
and you see somebody get on one there
should be a quote-unquote gimme and they
slam their ass in like less than a
second it's unreal man have you ever
seen one yeah you've been 100 bucks off
why I've never been I might go Saturday
sweet yes I'm gonna get really looking
forward to going with Saturday well much
different work yeah so much different I
want to get that ambiance we got you I
have a brother-in-law that did a lot of
the
Broncos for a while yeah I wrote the
horses right oh yeah bucking horses and
did you start with that so we grew up on
a ranch and that's kind of the first
thing you get on as a kid is horses
because we have cattle cattle need to be
worked move to different pastures so I
started out on a little tiny mini pony
yeah add wood I wouldn't have my own
reins how you control them dad would
just take them and time to his saddle in
a way we'd go I just hold on I was two
three years old yeah yeah a lot of guys
start on sheep oh yeah yeah yeah believe
it or not a lot a lot of guys that's
what that's it sounds like right but
like little kids riding sheep you know
does that pay seventy dollars to watch
on a hardcore sheep seven so I mean yeah
I go 80 man if it's Sunday only the
Lord's there yeah we have a question
that came in right here from somebody
let's get to it here
hey Jeff say Theo drew from central
Indiana here I grew up idolizing bull
riders in the early and mid 90s guys
like Tuffy Thurman Cody Lambert Laney
Frost
Ty Murray you know all the guys from the
eight seconds movie questions for you
Jess I got a three parter here bodacious
is obviously one of the most famous
Bulls ever on the circuit just curious
if there is a bull today that you think
compares to him secondly follow up with
that is is there a favorite bull name
that you have that you've come across
over the years and thirdly my question
is the stature become a factor in bull
riding or is it just the size of the
cojones that you have good luck this
year on the circuit man defending that
strap go get him gang gang good question
I nailed it
yeah he's into it man that's beautiful
yeah that uh Ty Murray is that the guy
yeah yeah that's the only bull rider
that I've ever heard of and I think I
really country songs actually I heard
some reference in a couple of songs see
that's like me like I like I grew up
idolizing those guys
I knew I didn't have the cojones to be
one of them it was like how do how do I
stay involved I talk about yeah I know
my butt that's great though and I love
the way you say you want to introduce
people to it because yeah if I'm for the
first time it's almost like even one in
this podcast like I want our listeners
to know right what it's like you know
and what's going on what do you think
about his question there they were good
what did you ask about bodacious right
at first I Vulcan like a bowl like right
now yeah shoot
smooth operator and a Heartbreak Kid
those are the top two bulls in the world
right now but a bowl that kind of
reminds me of bodacious is a bull called
High Chaparral and that's a bull that
nobody wants to get on like bodacious
back in the day he was notorious for
hitting guys in the face and I can't
imagine when you drew him you were happy
about it it's kind of like this bull
he's just kind of gross he's huge he's
about 20 100 pounds and he's just when
you see your name by him or you see got
him you're just like [ __ ] me
just a big scary monster he's a bad boy
huh yeah and do they breed him like do
you know who their parents are do you
get the lineage on him or anything like
that yeah they have a they have a I
guess a website and paperwork on them
and all sorts of things you can see
their granddaddy their great great yet
they're more custom the DNA tests these
Bulls so to make sure because High
Chaparral if somebody's trying to sell
you a son of bodacious you want to be
able to DNA test and make sure that you
can go back and actually confirm that
that really is a son of that bowl or
whatever so look at that thing man and
that's he's miserable look at the thighs
on that thing at Romney this girl I went
to school with that really yeah yeah
yeah it's gonna be Jessica she brought a
lasso to school every day really yeah
yeah it's ad hoc like what grade was
this rope somebody up dude
great it was time for a dance bro you
never change that's right you wasn't
asking her is it country girl she'd
bring you right here and that was it
dude sometimes it's got to be that way
though oh yeah cuz I was shy well yeah I
looked for girls like that like I'd be
in the corner like at the wall while
everybody else was dancing like just
open she would show up because I'm the
only guy here by myself so why not oh
dude you talking to a guy I used to go
eight seconds on the chaperone oh sorry
are there so other rumors of bulls that
are out there that are coming up that
you're like oh man that's
big you know yeah there's they have a
competition for little Bulls they put a
dummy on them it's like a 30 pound dummy
and they can click it off with a button
and they let those Bulls buck and they
mark them and they have their own
competition so you see a lot coming up
from there and those are bucking dudes
man they are when they're that young
that little and have that much athletic
ability to them they're freaking
incredible so this whole like there's a
lot of respect for the animal huh oh
yeah if we didn't have those bulls we
wouldn't have a job yeah what would we
ride sheep on Sundays yeah that'd be a
little bit I mean I'd watch it but you
know gosh 80 bucks dude
they measure the big sheep people start
grooming sheep breeding would be a big
deal nowadays if that was the case open
hordes on to putting Viking helmets tie
them to their head paying them different
colors put numbers on them like racecars
why wouldn't you oh that Tony Stewart
sure that thing's day smoke smoke it's
got kind of a gray color to it I think
yeah that's a bad ramp that's a bad room
right there bad room um so you're in
there now what do you do with your hand
a lot of time I see the guys have taught
you tie your hand in or what goes on
there yeah it's a rope and it's pretty
much tree sap we put on the rope to help
us hang on to them okay so you're not
tired really yo we're tied in there and
it's I mean that's the scariest thing is
that you are tied in there and you are
in there for the long haul it's it's a
rope it just goes around kind of their
brisket area and you put it across your
hand and then you wrap it around your
hand so you're like locked in there and
and your legs or what yeah they're in
there in chaps but those shafts really
do nothing for you
they might protect you from a little
skiff but they're just there for show
really they're loose they're not
strapped to anything okay so how do I be
able to move their legs now the only
thing you're tied in with is your hands
so the rest your body's free to move and
that's when you see guys they're hanging
by their hand once they get bucked off
is and I hang up we call it oh and
that's bad news baby yes I get it all
and is there a type of body type
sometimes I'll look at these guys body
tight front on a bull and it's like okay
that guy looks like you know everything
kind of like he's his height like that
is there a body type that does best in
the sport yeah
order yours a little better you want to
be skinny but you want to be as strong
possible as you can be and then that's
pretty much it really you don't want to
be overweight and you don't want to be
too tall makes it tougher yeah so yeah I
couldn't do it I'm overweight I can't do
it I waited out of the deal that was my
problem so when a guy likes a just gets
on a bull what are some things you're
talking about like from the announce
honestly like for him it's pretty simple
you know here's a two-time world champ
like last year when he when he came back
cuz that's what people don't realize is
like this is a guy that missed what nine
events last year nine out of our 26 27
events that we have so he misses
essentially you know a big chunk of the
season broke his collarbone when he
comes back you know he's got to fight
his way back up
so he's climbing the ranks and it's like
okay this guy won two events he's now
won three events you know he missed all
this season so when we got to the world
finals in Vegas I mean it was it was the
best race ever because it was him and a
Brazilian kid josée and it literally
came down to the last day it came down
to Sunday which you know a lot of sports
will fabricate that you know it's gonna
be tough it's gonna come down to the
final shot and we know it's not because
somebody's gonna pull away
I didn't happen last year so it's such a
fun story to tell but like we talked
about some of the injuries that they've
dealt with you know how good they've
done everybody's got a different story
you know like if a guy just had a baby
two weeks ago he's had to leave home
right you know he's had to leave that
baby at home get on the road go put his
life on the line to buy diapers for that
baby there's no guaranteed contracts in
this sport it's so different than
everything else man because you know
these guys they have to be successful
they have to ride they have to win to
make any money it's so different than
every other sport in the world so
there's no like oh we're gonna pay for
this whole season no matter what nope if
you do good enough you'll get sponsors
that'll pay yeah but that contracts
based on your performance at the events
and how many you go to so if you get
hurt the first event of the year and
you're out for the year
there's in the contract there's a little
money you'll get but you're not getting
paid that well that's why like when you
see a guy he and he's riding with a
broken leg you know or he's got a broken
collarbone and just gonna throw some
tape on that [ __ ] and go try it again
like they do it because that's
the only way they get paid wow they're
the toughest in the world man
and a collarbone sounds like is that one
of the premier injuries is that
something you really don't want to get
like what's what are some of the
injuries that are that you'll face and
what are something that can really take
you out you know of course broken bones
but groins a lot of time old bull riders
and bull riders nowadays it's so common
torn groins torn knees stuff like that
it really sucks cuz you can't just go in
and with the broken leg you could plate
it and you could probably ride in two
weeks but torn groin I've sat out three
months before with the torn groin just
waiting on it to heal because you can't
squeeze your bowl if you don't got a
torn groin and that's your bread and
butter right there so that's what you're
doing some when you're on there you're
squeezing your legs in oh yeah you're
trying to stay on you've got your hand
locked in down tight them in your crotch
it's yeah you slide up so it's right
right there you're kind of up on your
legs right there yeah yeah crazy
we got a question that came in right
here let's get to this one right here
yep oh no that's probably that's about
the longest I've stayed out but in 20
growing that pretty common 2017 at New
York I got stepped on I broke four ribs
collapsed my lung and lacerated my liver
and it was about three weeks out from
World Finals so I had to ride at the
World Finals that year with with broke
ribs and that stuff so you know what I
just realized like both of your world
title seasons were like when you got
really really hurt mm-hmm now I know
what this is well I have yet wood in all
my it's a nice table I'm nice I love
this place my four years of the PBR I've
never won a full season healthy which is
expected as a bull rider but there's
guys that'll go to they might miss one
event a year but over the course of four
years they one of the other broadcasters
on CBS that does PBR he totaled it up
and I've missed a total of one year I've
sat out three months my first year three
four months my next year three months in
2018 and three months last year all
sorts of so it's is so it's pretty kind
is it pretty common at some doesn't make
it through the end
our season doesn't make every race in
your heart to find somebody that's gonna
stay healthy and make it to every single
event because I mean it's just you
you're the little things like he was
talking about in a shoot you're
surrounded by solid steel and you know
you're getting banging around ACLs MCLs
are pretty common groins are pretty
common and when you're doing this three
four five times a week in every single
weekend even when the televised tour is
not on like when they're not going to a
place like LA or Anaheim they're going
somewhere and they're getting on
practice bulls you get hurt in a
practice band too so I don't know III
think it's impossible for a guy to stay
100% healthy all year long
is there a practice that they've made
like a mechanical practice that's that's
actually helpful that works
yeah there's mechanical barrels that go
up and down kind of give you the feeling
of one there's mechanical bulls that
spin all that sorts of stuff I don't
usually ride the mechanical ones there's
a barrel made that's on Springs that
goes up and down to kind of give you the
rhythm feeling I got one of those at
both my places and I'll get on that a
couple times during the week just to
give myself to feel and kind of do that
and what uh we got a question that came
around here let's get to this one right
here that's what up feel my question for
Jess is what kind of training regimen do
you have to follow to be a bull rider
are you out at bars riding mechanical
bulls or you lifting weights every day
Gang Gang question right here what is it
man what do you guys what do you do I
just kind of work out there's there's
guys that can drink beer during the week
and not work out at all and it works for
them what so many guys different things
work for them but what works for me is I
got a little sweat shop it's a twelve by
twenty building I got one in Montana one
in Texas at our places and I get in
there crank that sucker up to 110
degrees get in there and lift weights
work out and so I'm grinding all week
long to come here there's one guy that
that works for I don't work for anybody
else when you think about it there's one
guy that can get away with with drinking
and not working out like everybody else
is pretty regimen right now too - oh
okay yeah maybe two - Alta and has it
changed a lot because in stand-up comedy
it used to be that you had to have yet
it'd be out doing drugs you had to be
partying you had there was a lifestyle
that kind of went associated with
getting up on the stage at night and now
it's changed like a lot of the
comedian's an hour sober a lot of them I
mean Joe Rogan is a fitness guru I mean
he's shredded yeah sure sure David I'd
love to see you do four seconds on Joe
Rogan oh my god man that dudes a monster
yeah he's a beast I wonder if anybody
would ever have a bully Joe Rogan bro
that would be amazing
we'll make it happen yeah it happens
just Jo ro GaN just tell me he's cool oh
he's really cool man he's just he's also
inspiring that's the thing like I think
five years ago people thought a lot of
people thought oh he's just this
meathead guy yes just you know doing a
podcast but he's such a good he
remembers everything and he's so curious
man like he always he really wants to
know yeah and then he retains the
information he's so he's so intelligent
and I love the fact that like he does
the podcast and he doesn't care who's on
there
he doesn't care for democrat-republican
where you come from yeah like he's
invested yeah he is and he really is
it's not like I cook with him yet really
is just trying to genuine yeah genuine
he's really trying to learn which is
cool like I struggle with a lot of times
I'll bring my own thoughts and
perspective anything but he really does
a good job of just staying trying to
learn yeah that's cool um so is it is it
different now though like where a lot of
guys are working out more it's a lot
more like okay we're in this this is a
sport we're in this to make money this
is my livelihood it's not like you know
I'm drinking I'm sad at the bar like you
know the kind of the country song vibe
that used to go along with it yeah
today's borders are a lot of athletes
back in the day
PBR used to be sponsored by Bud Light
and they'd bring Bud Light in after the
blow rottens and everyone just kind of
would drink and just hang out not very
many people worked out and they loved
going to the bars not that we don't
still but back in the day it was kind of
just a routine and ritual after the
boride and everyone goes to the bars we
have fun ride bulls the next day dude
I've been around for like a dozen years
or so and the two might be seen in two
generations I've seen it's it's nine-day
different when I first came in it was
like man how do you keep up with these
guys because it was the Wild West and
those guys they'll tell stories now
and like say most of those guys are
sober now and they're like holy crap how
did we live through that now it's like
you see the guys and you know they're
waking up in the morning they're having
breakfast they're going to the gym
they're doing yoga and whatever they do
during the day and then they're showing
up in they're treating it like a sport
because they've realized that the Bulls
are getting better the holes are getting
better and better and more athletic and
so they have to they have to step their
game up you know he's you're hard though
cuz sometimes it's tough as a convenient
to let go of that old lifestyle it's
tough like I'll feel like a wimp
sometimes you know in like a
psychological way sometimes like oh I'm
you know on the side you know hanging
out with the guys afterwards staying up
all night and yes smoke is he just
partying all night you know
oh yeah like I would love to just I
would love if I could be as successful
as I am with not working out at all
drinking beer just eating [ __ ] food
because I love candy and stuff but I I
hold my back self back from eating it
all because it ain't gonna help with my
riding so everybody though like like
everybody wants to be successful and not
work and like oh I get a little light
out full of nerds right you know I put
two star veneers on get on that bastard
gobstoppers toppers is more of a lot I
don't know about gobstoppers man do when
you got on a Gobstopper dude and you
really went in on that vest and the ones
that changed like flavor halfway through
yeah good old days
damn is like a threesome for your tongue
ah like everything it was did uh how
much how much money does a rider make
you know you don't have to exaggerate it
I'm not trying to pick into your life
but ya know it's uh it's just it's so
different those lower end riders if
you're at the bottom of the top 35
you're still making 100 200 thousand a
year just because there's so much money
in the PBR whereas if you win the World
title it's a million dollar bonus Wow
and when in the World Finals it's a
three hundred thousand dollar bonus
there's so many incentives and with
winning an event when in the World
Finals everything that if you have a
really good year you can make 1.8
million
see that's where I get mad because they
start talking about you know the world
champ gets a million dollar bonus
there's a guy sitting on the bench for
the Knicks that sucks that's making a
million dollars and these guys are way
too uh fur way
better you know I think the sports way
more interesting you know it's way more
intense and like that bothers me I want
all these guys to make millions is it
growing the one he's got a hormone he's
got to start coming into it oh yes all
eyeballs
yeah eyeballs um is there another
country that's coming along with bull
ride and that's like that Pete you don't
you don't think about you know you think
of it as I mean especially growing up in
America I think of it as an American
kind of sport is that true is that no
shoot we got Canada Australia Brazil
Mexico everyone has the PBR Association
there and they ride in it but the
toughest ones are the Brazilians they're
unbelievable they have to man it's their
life like they leave everything you know
you think about it Brazil's not a really
they're not a really rich country yeah
and a lot of these guys have grown up
with nothing and so they leave home they
come over here and it's like this is all
they do so you see a bunch of Brazilians
living in the same little circle they
get up they worked out they practice
they they eat together they do
everything together they don't have all
the distractions of the rest of the
world that you know like just seeing our
families and everything that we do
normally oh yeah they don't have it so
they're laser focused they're so good
man there's something there's a there's
a special value in having that struggle
and having that extra chip that you
can't you can't imitate it like even as
I find as I get a little more
comfortable like started making some
money this past year it's hard to go
back to it's hard to get that same
mentality of when you have nothing yeah
when everything is on the line you know
when you have to stay like it's like a
chip inside of yourself that you can't
it's hard to replicate it yeah you know
I think it's that way with anything
though like like once you see a certain
level like even day-to-day like if I
have a really good Monday I don't want
to x' day to suck you know because then
I feel like the week's wasted so it's
like you got to maintain this level
that's why they always say like you know
people that our superstars are usually
the loneliest people because they push
their self to this level and it's so
hard to come back down you know what I
mean yeah and so I see that with these
guys like they're constantly pushing
themselves and if they buck off one bull
it like ruins their week I am and they
got to forget about it and turn around
because they got to do it again tomorrow
if you have a shitty rod in the first
rod right so Friday you don't have a
good rod they call it a rod what are
they
yep Oh God you have a tough ride at the
first the first go do you have a chance
in that Saturday to make it back up and
to get into Sunday yep
so this events a little different from
normal they take the top 25 into the day
too so if you're outside of the top 25
and you buck off your weekends done
whereas I'm second right now and I'm
almost guaranteed to ride tomorrow but
on a regular weekend you're guaranteed
to so if you suck Friday you better
forget that [ __ ] and just push it aside
because you got another one Saturday and
you got to make the most of it and what
does it do to your mentality if you have
a tough Friday does it affect it or are
you able to kind of scrap and just get
right in that's the thing it's everyone
it's 90% mental and Bloor and you can
put in all that work and it's not going
to matter if you get to the boride and
you see your bowl you're like oh man I
don't like the looks of him then you're
screwed you just got to be positive
about everything even if you buck off
you got to be like well I got tomorrow I
got a good bowl even if he's not good
I'm gonna make him good and I'm gonna
stay on him sorry to interrupt this
episode one of my favorite episodes
actually I want to let you know that
support for this past weekend comes from
you know manscaped manscaped they are
number one in men's below-the-belt
grooming everything below your belt it's
a real can be a risky area sometimes you
got something down there and some time
yeah you don't know what's going on you
got so much overgrowth and everything
the neighbors are complaining you know
your monkey grasses is is infecting
their Bermuda Front but things can
change manscaped offers
precision-engineered tools for your
family jewels
my experience with manscaped has been
good i'm able to trim up my my crotch
i'm able to trim up my shoulders my hips
even i get those sideburns on my hips I
get that hair on my hips look like I
have two big hair guns - big hair guns
on my hips like I'm mom like I'm Oh
couldn't you know kind of a wild western
guy shooting hair manscaped is forever
changing the grooming game with their
perfect package 2.0 we would love for
you to support the podcast you know we
need a we need your support and this is
a great
to do it with inside the perfect package
you'll find the electric trimmer called
the lawnmower 2.0 it has waterproof and
skin-safe technology so you don't have
to Nick your bag in your every now and
then you see somebody in their gonads is
all jacked up because it was down there
with a pair of school scissors don't
live like that the perfect package 2.0
also includes anti chafing performance
boxer briefs that keep your crotch and
stick and balls cool and smelling well
and right now you can get 20% off and
free shipping with the code théo th EO @
manscaped comm that's right get 20% off
and free shipping with the code th EO at
manscape comm that's 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscape comm use code Theo
support the podcasts now back to your
show when you win the shoot when they
open the gate this n is hitting me man
good stuff yeah dude I remember the
first time I ever did - in tobacco it's
like cherry Scholl or something and I
did like a half a can I was trying to
show my buddy up right I didn't know
anything about it dude and I had like
I'm a whole mouth was full of it how old
were you it's probably about fourteen
really and my buddies took his mom's car
we were going out we were partying you
know we weren't really were just driving
around but and I vomited out of the
front window out of the passenger side
yeah and he's like dude you can't sit up
there anymore but you got to sit in the
back
I vomited out of both of the back
windows oh yeah and so on the side of
the car we went and hung out at night
and then we went and parked the car in
the morning his mom thought he'd been
partying with the whole group of people
vomit on every window and they didn't
believe it I was just deal man he just
thought he wasn't do it real well yeah
got my first still don't believe to this
day she's like there's no way one child
vomited out of three windows my first
tobacco I was to my dad left it laying
there and I thought it would be a good
idea to just put it in my mouth take a
drink whatever it was not a good idea
puked came out both ends dad took me
outside garden hosed me off ran around
naked the rest of the day pretty
successful day mom still hates were you
2 or 22 yeah
anyways it was in college when you leave
this shoot right what do you look at
what do you look are you looking like is
your because sometimes I say like if
you're in the gym you're doing squats I
say look at the ceiling or something you
know there's like a place for your focus
what is it like yes they're at their
neck muscle that big hump they got on
them
you pretty much stare at that because
their shoulders is what you follow if
you look at their head they're some
bowls sling their head everywhere so if
you get too focused on that you're
you're gonna go cross-eyed during the
damn ride so if you look at their
shoulders you and you don't even really
go off of what you see it's all feel but
that's the best focus point just look at
their shoulders yet stay right down in
there yep it's pretty much just you
don't even know what's going on but
that's where you look and at a certain
point can you hear the crowd can you
hear when it's going good
I just I don't hear much when I'm riding
you know it's kind of and you want to
say you hear the whistle but you Daniel
don't even hear that and it's just
become a routine that when it gets
around to that eight second o'clock you
know it's time to get off and at eight
seconds what happens in a buzzer sounds
a whistle what goes on buzzer sounds in
the arena and then then it's your job to
get off them without getting killed so
it it almost gets harder than crazy
because you think like you just did your
job and like okay good job nobody still
got to get off get away not get hooked
ran over the worst part of the job is
before and after you get to work yeah
for these guys well we're lucky like
we've got bullfighters out there there
are there to try to distract the bull
make sure they get away but it's not
always that easy
what's the pot what's the way to
dismount so what how do you do that what
you pretty much if you whatever hand
your ID with you go away from it and you
well you go into it I guess you go
towards it and you kind of wait for that
bull to kick and you kind of lean back
and throw your leg over his back at the
same time and kind of let them throw you
out there and ideally you land on your
feet but it's kind of rare if you land
on your feet really yeah and the second
you hit the ground you're scurry and off
you have a lot of time you see that just
kind of right yeah yeah move yeah that's
wild and so when the bull step then you
got stepped on last year you said 2017
2017 yeah I got stepped on and it
I mean of course it took my breath away
and it was like oh [ __ ]
did you know what had happened oh yeah
when it happened I was like oh I just
broke everything in there and that's the
scariest part getting stepped on it you
don't know if it just punctured
something what that's the scariest damn
thing and I rolled over and that bowl
was right there and that bullfighter
went in and took it took him away but
then I had to get up and run out of the
arena essentially with four broke ribs
collapsed lung and lacerated liver yeah
so if you laying that you're screwed you
if you got a broke leg you got to get
the hell out of there it is the most
common thing when they when they stepped
Lee is it usually I guess you don't know
where they're gonna step is no yeah it's
usually broke ribs
yeah broke ribs she can guarantee every
time you get stepped on pretty much you
know Wow
I don't see NFL guys running around
these planes you don't see it you don't
see it anywhere else
and I think that that's kind of the the
intrigue like say you know that brings
new people and that's why it's the
fastest growing sport because you don't
see that you don't see guys getting
carted off in in our arena rarely do you
see a stretcher because the guys want to
walk out yeah if they've got busted ribs
they've got a busted spleen like they
still want to walk out they don't want
to help yeah yeah I mean and I don't
know if that's an old-school kind of
sign of weakness or if it's just hurry
up cuz we got to keep the show going or
what it is but it's crazy I've seen guys
get up and walk out with broken necks
like insane insane injuries if probably
that adrenaline rushing so much too
still huh oh yeah yeah the only time
I've been carted off I got knocked out
actually and when I came to I really
didn't come to until I got me back to
the sports med room but I guess I woke
up out in the arena and when I hit the
ground he kind of he bent me weird so I
woke up out in the arena and I didn't
know what the hell I was saying but I
was saying oh my [ __ ] back hurts and
they're like what where and I'm like I
don't know I was just I didn't know what
the hell I was saying because I was
still knocked out essentially and
they're like oh god well we got a card
him out his back might be broke and then
they get me in the sports med room and I
really come to and I'm like what the
[ __ ] am i doing on a stretcher like well
you said your your back hurt it's like
[ __ ] I don't know what I was saying and
I
now realize what's really going on so
that's the only time I've been card away
cuz essentially I was just speaking
mumbo-jumbo because I was still out I
guess like being drunk he can't hold me
accountable yeah you know when you've
been stepped on yeah
do they have two routers or one bull at
the same time do you ever do that how to
seen it before yeah not at our events
but when you're going around in the
practice pen anything goes is so is that
like is that a sport you think that'll
grow in a song like is that impossible
man I hope so Oh like a tag-team kind of
thing you imagine you just start putting
teams together my brother nice to sit on
the toilet at the same time we're kids
sometimes facing each other
no no no you couldn't back do you have
to go back-to-back like where did like
told us not that big notice had that big
when you gotta have good name
do we see over the kid Roy's house and
he would play all these games he was
kind of a now in hindsight I think he
was kind of a homoerotic kind of
judgment or he preferred men as lovers
you know but we were kids we didn't know
right he would make us get in his
bathtub and like he would play
battleship or whatever and he would get
in his toilet and be like the captain
from the really like hat and everything
no he might I don't know feeling like a
captain's hat or something but he was
just getting their bark orders at us
would you say his name was Roy don't you
think like everybody has a Roy in their
life and sometimes though like somehow
someway somewhere yeah this dude I mean
he yeah he would say oh the seas are
getting high and stuff and like we'd
have to turn on the water and make it
all like crazy you never have to like
stick your face in the water and like
blow bubbles did you pretend you're out
like the motorboat never got in the
toilet is yellow stuff he was kind of a
mystery it was like he was the captain
you were the seamen yeah yeah he was a
wild cat ended up going into the
military dude really yeah so he got in
there man that's good so now he's legit
captain yeah now he has mindset he was
going for it you were basically his
little plastic green army he was just
practicing for the real thing
you contributed basically you were in
the service
yeah
and help prep him for a career that's
good [ __ ] man thank you for your service
because yeah he really went into
military man oh we got a question from a
guy right here here we go yo what up
video mr. Lockwood
I see boy blight from Nebraska um my
question is what's the craziest [ __ ]
y'all ever wrote do you said you're from
the stray animal belt
there's wonder if you ever wrote
anything or anything crazy you know um
you know no including big gals or
anything like that but yeah Gang Gang
howhow do you think that guy is right
now uh uh he could be pretty hot he's
pretty hot he could be pretty I let me
think uh what you got I mean I guess
it's a bowl probably the craziest thing
no I got so at home during the winter
when I was still living up at home
everyone around the place traps you know
traps animals coyotes for fur foxes well
one day we go out in the pasture where
we had a trap set a foot trap and an
antelope was stuck in it we're like aw
[ __ ] now we got to get this thing out of
there and so we get it out I'm like [ __ ]
it get your snapchat out I'm gonna ride
it up Saro I let this antelope get up
and I wrote it off no well it didn't
have the same kind of feel that doesn't
same kind of vibe of what was going on
now it was freaking the hell out I mean
kind of sort of the same thing but a lot
smaller than a bowl it was fun
did we had a boy I talked about this we
had a kid with no legs on our basketball
team at one time so we had a big black
guy named Terrence who was like our
center on the team and he had to carry
him for like half the game and we carry
him around and try to get him to get
buckets you know so that's about the
craziest riding I've ever seen because
he would kind of wear him on his back a
little bit backpacks yeah like if you
had to play defenders would hold both of
his arms down and then he would just
play defense with the other arm you know
but uh the craziest thing I ever been on
probably a strong woman one time in
Indiana really yeah because it gets cold
and they like lift weights that kind of
I'm like some women have that they're
kind of thick but they it's like it's
kind of like strong fat honey you know
like the in-between like powerlifter
strong yeah yeah like they don't look
like big veiny muscles but like yeah
they know yeah tell you don't want to
[ __ ] with it and the fat it's kind of
tight you know they get that tight fat
which I really like man cuz it's not
really fat yeah it's not really not
really muscle yeah what is it's like
Wagyu I yeah it's good yeah which is
more lesser there's a reason it's more
expensive yeah so you get it yeah this
girl was really Wagyu man and uh I
remember that being one kind of the
largest thing that I've ever really kind
of I guess ridden really I got on a
camel one time in a County Fair
no [ __ ] that's where because they
started doing it for a photo shoot we
were doing a rodeo and they're like hey
we got to get a picture of you on this
camel and I'm scared of heights
and then the camel like started kind of
just jumping and I've never been so
scared in my life
never like I I flew on a and through a
snowstorm on the way here and the planes
started doing this wasn't as scary is
being on the back of a camel that just
started like popping up and down
terrifying man
can you imagine telling people you got
bucked off a camel like that's the worst
thing you could ever do in your life I
could imagine in some countries it's uh
it's happening it's probably like a like
a pride thing yeah like you're not
somebody until you get bucked off yeah
yeah but camel yeah are there new
animals that people are starting to ride
besides Bulls is there anything else
that's coming up like you're seeing like
in the in the world not really you know
you just got your common bucking horses
bucking bulls but that's that's it and
is there a difference when you're on the
bors's they call them Broncos right yep
so if you're a Bronco is there a big
difference between that kind of rod and
the bull riding it's definitely
different you don't hang on by a rope
you got a you kind of got uh praying
it's it's kind of connected to their
face and it clips on it's like a like a
holder goes around them uh-huh and you
hold on by that and then you're in a
saddle instead of a rope around them and
you got to keep yourself in that saddle
so it's a lot different is it tougher is
one tougher than the other
I'd have to say Bora and just because
you don't have a saddle that you can
actually sit in and keep yourself in
you're just hanging on by that rope so
in the bull you're sitting on their back
ear really it's not a saddle that you're
sitting in nope it's just a pretty much
a 20
nope just stuck around them and your
hands in it and that's all you got to
keep yourself on so you're not so but
you're sitting you're putting your legs
into something on there no nope just
around there around their back and their
sides that's it like there is nothing
that is keeping you in there but your
hand and your balance and do people
because you're a young guy you're 22 you
said yep three do people do older guys
like did they get upset like how does
that kind of go that you're eat is it a
young guys sport yeah 100% like you know
you've got to be able to not only bounce
back from injury but you've got to be so
quick and like you see guys that have
been around for ten years or so they
start to get those injuries start to
pile up and it starts to slow them down
just like with anything else you know
like you start to compound all those
injuries and you know your body doesn't
react the way it used to and so it's
definitely a young guys sport you know
you hit probably hit prime what like
mid-20s yep you know I have 26 if a
guy's 30 he's an old man in this sport
and we got some like we're lucky right
now we've got a couple of guys that are
like 36 37 I don't know how they do it
yeah but yeah they're different they are
so tough and they stay in such great
shape it's different than any of us
being 36 37 Red Bulls is their
discrepancy between like the American
and the Brazilian riders like is there
any like country beef a little bit or
not really no we have won nicest guys
ever you have one event it's called the
global Cup and we do it at AT&T Stadium
where the Cowboys play and there's yeah
it's crazy man thanks we can think about
that yes you're gonna be there next
weekend yep yep and that's it you'll see
it on the big screens when you're there
and everything they take the football
field out they put arena down there and
every country has a team and so that's
the only time all year long that you'll
see guys like really raised in that
Brazilian flag or the USA flag it's
pretty cool because I feel like you know
everybody wants something here yeah it
is it's our Olympics you know
essentially so has it ever been an
Olympic sport bull rod there when was it
back early thousands late 90s had been
too terribly long ago they had
like Idaho or something they had a
Olympic rodeo yeah I got my dad home
made that [ __ ] up no dad I'm serious
yeah I don't know and they gave me you
know that like it like at one time they
were they were testing it out trying to
make it but mmm I don't know man
curling's only epic sport why didn't
boil ride I watched curling the other
night for about an hour right it's like
a corn hole from Italia Italy really
yeah they they grow in a town in Italy
oh really yeah I thought it was like all
Canadian I do the word they might have
been playing Canada I think at the time
but these girls they were doing well
real I thought I don't know what was
going there but it sounded exciting late
night I gotta clear my thought I was so
much [ __ ] nicotine in my throat as I
say I'm feeling left out like I'm the
only one not spitting here maybe I just
spend the foreword that six for about 35
minutes live we got a guy right here in
a photo lab who has a question and this
bull rider how many times this man
listen to that Tim McGraw hitter before
he gets on that bull going three point
seven seconds Gang Gang you thought that
last guy was high madness I think what a
shame I think yeah this is coming in red
this guy was living enough yeah this is
buck developed like his eyes are so
close he doesn't even know the camera is
not on his fan I like to see him go
eight seconds with his eyes open I'd
like to see him go to lunch like outside
of his apartment that's awesome
is that a Nickelback record on the wall
explains so much is there a song is
there hype music what are people
listening to Travis Scott what are you
guys doing my song has dire straits
money for nothing Oh what they play when
I start going and dude so when do they
start the intro music is it like UFC
they do when they come out of the when
they come out you know when we get in
that bucking shoe that's when they start
it okay
pretty much I need to play the whole
time you were rotten yeah they they got
a Music Mixer at the events each weekend
so they'll play that and then when I nod
he'll mix up something different and
it'll play a freaking Jam up song when
I'm going hey you should switch it up
and play a genuine
my pony oh that's not a bad idea that's
their blood they play baby shark before
they have done that I I introduced him
last week after he wrote his bull I
introduced him as mr. Halley Kenzel
because his wife's a world champion
barrel racer - and so we kind of changed
up his name a little bit less last week
- and did you meet her on the circuit
yeah not on this but we have a couple
different events each year that kind of
collide with PBR we get invited to some
and I met her at one of those nice man
and did you know immediate was there do
you I mean how did that break down with
you and the lady it was good I I knew
she was gonna marry her before I even
met her yeah and I just know that's NOLA
so I'm doing interviews for like this
little digital network we had here and I
asked him I said describe the perfect
woman because he's what 19 at the time
someone 18 19 yeah we know either and
it's like you know all these teenage
girls are flocking over these guys and
like young Cowboys described the perfect
girl and he looks the camera dead in the
eye and he goes hailey Kenzel and gives
it this week and he had never even met
her never there we go he met her right
there to put it out in the universe
happened yeah man that's beautiful dude
thank you and so her sport her when she
does its barrel racing yep and so that's
on a horse yeah and it's only pattern
three barrels okay and so when you say
that cloverleaf pattern what is that you
just you go around there's sort of
right-hand turn okay they're both on the
triangle yeah and they start at one of
the barrels yeah you go you start
probably a hundred feet out from the
barrel and then you run at the barrel go
around it then go to the next one go
around it go to the third one go around
it and haul ass home that's crazy
that's Wow yeah and uh do you did you
have parents that Road
yeah my mom competed in the barrel race
and then my dad wrote the bucking horses
so went from the time I was little up
until I think mom quit going when I was
probably around six seven I was getting
hauled to all those rodeos and
that's kind of how I took a liking to
the bull ride and I would see those
bulls go with rodeos and big scary
baseball bats on their heads and I just
took a liking to him for some reason now
he's got a 19 year old brother that's in
the same league he is now then
just got into the major leagues that's
trying to beat that ass dang any of some
people is that starting to become a
thing oh yeah they're they're loving it
that me and him are on at the same time
it's kind of cool that the Lockwood
brothers are competing at this highest
level of bull riding dude that's
beautiful mood oh she wrote this back is
he single I'm 19 that's perfect for
people just listening there was someone
sent in just a snapchat photo and it's a
girl hitting on Jesse's brother oh nice
get that tag I'll get it to him yeah
there we go love connection it starts
here there will be a Beretta
it all starts on the Internet these days
man you can officiate it damn right I
can do people get you at you get asked
to officiate a lie man we actually had a
bull rider here a couple of years ago
that asked me to and I kind of laughed
it off and and didn't really think much
about it but yeah we've had some weird
requests like not Bruce Buffer making
videos to walk people down the aisle
with my voice kind of things but yeah
like I've been asked I've done some
funerals that weren't fun obviously but
it's part of life you know oh yeah but
I've never done one yet I want to do one
I want to do I want to I want to do the
wildest wedding ever
yeah just mess it up yeah make it
something they can remain a kit right
yeah it's got to be life's got to be fun
man I'm sure man that's great I love
that Nick made any other good questions
that came in we had another one from the
guy in the photo lab ah this ought to be
interesting
I got another one for you man
lost a tooth or something out of his
pockets on that book let me know gang
gay gang well you ever lost your phone
or anything do you think your phone oh
did he say lose a tooth out of your
pocket said this guy's on a whole nother
planet right now have your methadone is
he from Oklahoma cuz I live next to a
lot of people that act like that
yeah the grill piece if you lost
something we don't know I can't even no
I haven't lost a tooth I haven't lost
nothing really when I'm riding maybe my
necklace broke off once that's all I can
think do you
wear a helmet sometimes you see guys
with a helmet on yeah yeah I know I've
never lost that I'd keep that sucker
strapped on tight that's my lifeline
everybody wear that is that mandatory
mandatory now you know for the younger
guys I think it's like 93 or 94 if you
were born or after if you're born after
94 it's mandatory it's so dangerous you
have to you have to protect the noggin
yeah we're finding out more and more you
know in all major sports with with so
much CTE and somebody had trauma so much
research we're starting to learn that
like you've got to find a way to protect
that dome and so all of our guys are
wearing helmets now is it harder to
defend do you find because you're right
now the year the champion yep
is it harder to defend that do you feel
it was it was it tougher in 2018 or 2019
when you were making that comeback I
think it was the first year it was
harder to defend whereas this year I'm
more experienced got more Bulls under my
belt at the top level I just feel it
it's just normal now that everyone talks
about though after you win your first
world title it's a world champion slump
the next year and I felt it it was true
but yeah you get you get put through so
much media at that point everyone wants
to talk to you use you for stuff but now
I'm just it's become normal to me and I
just deal with it and it doesn't affect
my riding no more did you notice like it
did your ego ever get involved because
egos a dangerous thing sometimes
something we don't even control you know
it'll grow inside of us without us
really wanting it to we don't realize it
yeah we'll think we're the most humble
guy and you can have this like you know
the dark edge of you kind of growing up
did you notice any of that no it never
happened my parents raised me pretty
good if it ever got to that they would
whoop me when I was little so I knew
when I got older it wasn't gonna happen
but that ego thing comes on those
championship Sundays it comes into play
there I think when when you go up and
you get to pick your Bowl in that top 15
oh really yeah so sometimes you get up
there and you feel that big energy
you're like yeah give me that one you
want to go with the biggest bad oh yeah
you're like you know let's run I'm the
man let's try them out hey here's a move
on dude and that's got a mentally affect
the other guys - were the like oh [ __ ]
he's out and big yep exactly your ego
gets ahold of it hold of you when you're
picking them bulls and make them other
guys take notice I think it's it's cool
when you see a guy that can have you
Boal he wants to and he steps up and he
picks the one that he knows is gonna be
the most difficult one and like he's
done that a couple of times you know and
and it's cool somebody will get it in
hit me that six brushes started a three
like my childhood I can't feel my ears
anymore
we got a question I'm a white kid right
here this guy looks a lot more domestic
gorillas in the background it probably
is day yeah of course it is yeah I was
wondering what your thought process was
going in to riding Heartbreak Kid Ganga
Ganga see he paid attention yeah that's
that bull we were just talking about
like that you got old me yeah I went to
the event and I'd ridden both my bulls
actually but I was really low on my
second one score wise and I was like
fifth in the event or something and I
was like well [ __ ] I gotta be a lot of
points if I'm gonna win it [ __ ] it give
me the hardest ride one he's net he'd
never been rode at that point he was he
was the bull that got left at the end of
the draft every weekend because everyone
was so scared of him didn't like him I
was like [ __ ] it give him to me and I
rode him and broke his streak and it was
awesome and then with you next week in
it then the next weekend I did it again
and I was kind of behind an event I'm
like [ __ ] it I did it once let's do it
again and I got him road again so really
oh yeah I'm one both of is know I ended
up second on second and both of them
because I was he made up those points
for me but that guy went in leading it
he just had so many points on me and so
the judges what are the judges for their
there they're scoring the guys and
they're scoring the animal so that's
like the thing that a lot of people
don't realize is like every one of these
Bulls is getting judged so that's why
the guys want there they want these
animals to be as well taken care of as
athletic as they possibly can because
they're watching to see how far the
question how difficult they are to ride
back and so they're marking them one two
fifty and then they're marking these
guys one two fifty on how easy they can
make it look or how stylish they can be
or if they're just floating by and just
barely getting by so you know they're
they're they're looking at the animal
and the rider and putting the scores
together and so when so when you go into
the
event when you go towards the end you
want to get your thinking okay I have
this many points right now yeah this
bull is like sometimes you have to pick
the best well you have to really get out
there on the best one oh yeah I kind of
evaluated okay I might be able to take a
mid-range bull right now because I'm
doing I'm up by so much right now yep
exactly
a lot of guys will try that strategy in
do you think I will you're on the Buller
so then are you thinking style like I'm
trying to do this with a certain Flair
or are you thinking I'm just trying to
stay on this animal so most the time
you're just you're just doing your job
doing whatever that keeps you in the
middle
staying on them but then if you're
riding and plumb easy you'll see guys
lift their leg and it's actually
spurring the bull and it's giving you
extra points essentially so it's showing
you're in domination and you're
controlling your ride and you're making
a bowl just look easy and that's what
they just so you yeah so you're
competing so you're not just trying to
stay on for eight seconds you're also
trying to impress the judges exactly
you're trying to get as much Flair in
your ad as you can dig up your score
there's a lot more to it like like you
think about it I know that man it's a
seconds goes by so fast when you think
about it but when you're watching so
much happen so quick there's a lot going
on
it's like watching Flint and when people
start a fire you know it's like watching
that exact process right there yeah just
trying to pack it all in yep and do you
go when so say when it's it's your
chance to go pick the bull will you go
look at them will you go down and spend
time looking at four before that Sunday
ride no you pretty much those top Bulls
you know exactly you've seen them
hundreds of times before that's and then
you get up on the cage out there and
it's with him and they got a big screen
of all the names and once you say that
they'll put your name beside him mark
him off so and on the tail the on the
action on the stuff you see on
television do you see them pick the
bulls or it's just matched up once they
show it it depends it depends on where
we're at and like obviously you know TV
produce and stuff because a lot of times
you know if he's got the number one pick
and that heartbreak kids in there you
know our fans at home on TV they want to
see it if that's not a potential if
there's not something big right off the
gate then they might not show it on TV
but in the arena it's interesting
because he has been getting up the last
few weeks and he'll look at me and go
what do you thinking I'm like no bull
rider don't put that pressure on me
unions ya know I'm an open mind guy yeah
you whatever he thinks I can win on I'll
take dance I'm one of those guys like I
want to see you guys be as high as they
can be every single time so that's
that's always my advice what's like kind
of the future of boron do you see a
change in do you see it is it great as
it is it's just gonna get better then
Bulls are they're producing them and
breeding them to just get better and
better so it if they don't keep doing
that with the bore out of soon there's
not gonna be a guy that rides all
weekend because the Bulls are just
getting better so and numbers have
dropped and bore out as I think the
amount of actual riders yeah yeah it's
dropped over time and we need to breed
some men back into this world and make
some blow routers out of them because
why do you think that is I want the
truth yeah I think because society is so
scared of everything that like we're not
you know taking what what is it the hot
off the garden hose you know that hot
hose that ha hose hit yeah like we're
not literate item we're not we're
keeping kids in a bubble all the time
we're not letting them get life
experiences we're not letting them get
their arm broke on the playground
we're so coddling yeah that we don't let
people have experiences and it's
something that you definitely have to
experience I mean and we just don't have
enough toughness in society yeah I mean
oh yeah we lose it out here I mean it's
going yeah many steps in the ocean yes I
changed out here do you think that do
you think that there will be like do you
think there will be like a resurgence of
more men wanting a rod well here's a
better question what do you think it is
that makes like if there's a young guy
sitting out there is like I wonder if I
could do this okay perfect
what up Theo what up jazz just have a
quick question I guess it's kind of a
serious one you know I've always wanted
to to learn how to ride bulls I come
from a long history of cowboys however
when my family moved here to the US
we moved into the city you know that
kind of part of our you know my family's
lifestyle was cut off man but I it's
it's something that nags me all the time
and it's just something that I want to
do that calls me man I wanna I want to
learn how to write some [ __ ] bulls
bro so I guess my question is what what
tips do you have man for somebody that
wants to get started and to just [ __ ]
do it
thank you feel Gang Gang brother Ganga
that's tough you know when you get older
it just gets tougher to learn it if you
don't start out real young I mean it's
not impossible but it definitely makes
it harder when you grow up wanting to do
it and you take those steps like getting
on sheep then you work your way up to
little calves and steers you work your
way up whereas you're this age you can't
start out on that sheet you got to go
straight into bulls it's just it's just
so hard when you get older but that
younger the younger kids that can start
out like that and get in with the right
people and make them take them
stepping-stones
really teach them correct and teach them
right it's just so much easier than
taking a full grown man and putting them
on a bowl because there's not Bulls easy
enough nowadays that you can learn on
really right there's no a lot of
beginner bulls really but I want to see
kids like from the city I want to see
kids that didn't grow up on a ranch
because we've got a couple of buddies
like there's a guy Shaun Willingham he
grew up wakeboard you know just an
extreme sport and it was that adrenaline
rush
yeah and that's you know that's why I
keep going back to the more eyeballs you
know I want kids to try it like because
who knows you don't have to grow up on a
ranch you don't have to grow up in a
saddle to be a cowboy you know and we
say that all the time at the PBR now
it's like like cowboy is such a broad
spectrum term that like if you've got
those hardcore base values the Cowboys
have come on you know come be part of us
come be one of us yeah this guy even
Walsh said uh that I follow on Instagram
and he's like a big surfer and he's big
into X Games and redbull type of stuff
and all of that just he's a just an
adrenaline junkie you know ya know into
and I would love to see him I would love
to see some of these guys crossover you
remember when the NFL went on strike
here like it's been
like maybe back in the early 2000s the
NFL went on strike whatever Chad
Ochocinco saw billboard that the PBR was
coming to town and he tweeted out that
he was gonna start bull riding and he
came and tried he went to Ty Murray's
house he started working on trying it
and this is an OCO cinco's prime and he
came to one of our events and he got on
a bull and the direct quote you can
YouTube this and look it up it's it's
him saying I don't understand why these
are not the highest-paid athletes in the
world I mean that's a guy that premier
athlete tried it and sucked at it yeah
like was horrible but it's just it's so
so tough yeah yeah the funniest part
about about this whole deal is they
didn't just put him on like a alright
bowler nerble this is the [ __ ] world
champion Bowl that year this is the
greatest Bowl in the world at this point
like let that just sink in oh my god I
would be so scared okay you can look
scary terrified but like he admitted
he's terrified and he's like okay we
good
and that's not a knock on him at all oh
man I think it takes yeah dude's got
huge balls just to try it we're gonna
get you guys out of here just a second
you gotta ride them I didn't know that
yeah it's crazy
all right says let's do this we man who
is out Wow good for him brah in that you
know Grady feels right now that he just
try how much respect do you have for a
guy that totally out of his element to
do that
I hope yeah it's right there in that
moment you have my whole perspective
sans changed so my perspective of him
saying yeah about most respect for that
guy yeah that's a while anybody that
tries that there's multi-million dollar
athlete and he just like I'm gonna try
Bora and just to just to see what's up
just to see Scott that million dollar
contract like yeah through it you know I
would have respect yeah that's beautiful
man thank you guys so much for being
here today man I knew you guys got a
ride that so the reason we're gonna kind
of uh we'll step out man but yeah
there's been some educational I'd love
for you guys come back sometimes you
generally thanks for doing this awesome
well yeah that Xin has hit me in the
head as it is here then that's six bro
love it I just went about 48 minutes on
that six yeah party yeah anymore
Kingston thank you guys so much best of
luck to both of you man game
gang run we'll see you guys in the
future British fans now I'm just
floating on the breeze and
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]